hello everyone and welcome to the game
that was proclaimed by leeches to be the
game of the month October I don't think
they've had something like this before
but now they do and I imagine they will
have a game of the month every month and
then maybe there will be a vote on the
the actual Game of the Year from all of
the millions millions of games that are
played so this game it's a Blitz game
it's a 3 plus two game 3 minutes plus 2
seconds increment and it's played
between two players who are unknown a
player with the wi pieces is rated 20
510 uh by the handle please resign now
and players with the black pieces is
John wamp rated two 20174 so quite a bit
of a rating difference uh as you will
also see from the moves that are played
so uh please resign now has the white
pieces and opens with Pawn to E4 and
what does John go for he goes for Pawn
to D5 he goes for the Scandinavian
defense or maybe she I have no idea who
is playing here uh we have e captures on
D5 Queen captures and now Knight to F3
now usually you will see Knight to C3
but sometimes okay Knight to F3 is
played uh but the John nonetheless goes
Queen to A5 he probably pre moved it in
expectance of Knight to C3 but okay it
has been played before even by Grand
Masters uh Bishop to E2 Knight to F6 and
now castles and here there are some
games where Bishop to F5 and Bishop to
G4 were were played but here we have C6
and it is now as of move five already
that we have a completely new game so
black going for the standard setup he
wants to have C7 and d8 ready for the
queen to retreat if needed uh we have
Pawn to D4 and now Bishop to F5 we have
Pawn to C4 grabbing more space in the
center Knight B to D7 Knight to C3 and
now just Pawn to E6 you could Advance it
all the way to E5 but E6 um does appear
to be more solid with have Bishop to E3
and The Rook to d8 nicely aligning The
Rook with the White Queen we have Pawn
to A3 preparing Pawn to B4 and Bishop to
D6 now uh B4 attacking the queen queen
to C7 and now even Pawn to C5 maybe a
bit premature as you are weakening the
B5 and D5 squares but remember it's a 3
minute plus 2 seconds increment game so
you have to play very fast uh Bishop D7
Bishop to F4 also very nice but uh he
decides to go a bit passive Bishop D7
and now Queen to B3 we have Pawn to A6
and now Pawn to A4 preparing Pawn to B5
we have Castle and pawn to B5 so going
with the queen side attack a captures a
captures and now even C captures and B5
now was probably a good ide idea to
strike in the center with E5 but he
captures on B5 Knight captures on B5 and
now Queen to
C6 uh so what do you do here Knight back
to C3 and now Knight to D5 and it looks
like black is uh definitely holding his
own against the 2500 player however this
move is already losing the game for
black now if White had enough time you
would of course find something like
captures captures captures captures and
just Rook to A7 win the B7 pawn and
that's pretty much it the pawn cannot be
defended if you try this then just
Bishop to F4 and you you haven't really
accomplished anything you're going to
lose the pawn white will get a pass C
Pawn you're going to put the Rook behind
the pawn and win the game very quickly
but like I said 3 plus two so Bishop to
B5 was played attacking the queen which
is also winning Queen to C7 and now
comes the move that probably made this
the game of the month and that is Queen
captures on D5 just taking the Knight
here and it looks like you're not
getting much okay you might get the
bishop as well but no you're going to
get this bishop the Knight the bishop
and the bishop on F5 so okay e captures
on D5 now Knight captures on D5 attacks
the queen and the undefended bishop on
E7 and notice how the bishop on F5 is
undefended as well and the E7 Bishop
will be captured with check so okay
Queen B8 we have Knight captures on E7
with with check King to h8 only move and
now Knight captures on F5 so you won
three pieces for the queen and you are
up a pawn so even by uh standards of
material you are now winning this game
as white but if black can you know muddy
the waters it's possible for black to
get back into the game as well so H6
Rook F to B1 nicely putting the Rooks on
the and B file Knight to F6 and now
Bishop to C6 going ruthlessly after that
B7 Pawn as well Queen C8 now attacking
the bishop and the Knight on F5 and now
there is only one way to save the game
uh not to save the game but to actually
win the game for white and that of
course is Knight to E7 you defend the
bishop and attack the queen so the queen
has to move Queen E6 attacks the Knight
and now Rook captures on B7 now look at
this uh funny triangle Rook defends the
Knight Knight defends the bishop and
Bishop defends The Rook so White's
position is very solid and he does have
two connected pass Pawns in the center
of the board
Rook to B8 and now comes Rook 8 to B1
and now we have Queen captures on E7
giving back the queen uh but of course
you guys are uh trickier than that you
will not fall for just anything feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for please resign now while I give you a
couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on not
falling for the trick and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Rook captur on B8 that's the winning
move for white because if you take the
queen uh you allow Rook captur on B1
with check then the bishop has to block
you lose the bishop as well then The
Rook has to block you take the Rook as
well and then after Knight captures yes
white is still up to pawns but black is
up the exchange and should have
additional uh re sufficient resources to
to draw this game nicely so Rook
captures on B8 that's the move you have
to play congratulations if you found it
Rook captures Rook captures on B8 with
check King to H7 and now just Pawn to H3
uh you don't need this move but it's uh
much nicer to not worry about the back
rank issues especially if you're low on
time and now you're just going to uh
make the position very solid and do your
best to advance the pawns as safely as
possible Pawn to G6 we have Rook to B7
now uh Queen to E6 and Knight to E5 the
the F7 Pawn cannot be defended and
that's pretty much it Knight to D5 was
played now comes Rook captures on F7
with check King to G8 and now Bishop
captures on D5 Queen captures and pawn
to C6 so C7 C8 is coming and there's
nothing you can do about that pawn to G5
was played Pawn to C7 and now Queen to
C6 guarding the C8 Square giving up the
queen for The Rook on F7 but that's all
there is Knight captures on C6 King
captures on F7 and now C8 Queen and he
was in this position un move 39 that
John wamp resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here you're up a
queen Queen Knight and and Bishop and of
course you are getting uh checkmated
very very quickly regardless of what you
do let's say H5 you will get Knight to
E5 with check King G7 Queen to D7 with
check anything you play doesn't really
matter Queen to F7 with check and now
any move with the pawn will result in a
nice Knight to G6 Checkmate uh so yeah
very nicely done but Mr please resign
now uh ala says that this is the game of
the month October do you guys agree was
it was it really that special I mean so
many games millions of games are being
played every month uh does this game
deserve the game of the month award uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Kevin
Clark Camilo he Schwarz Randall ingol
Stefan rovic and Andreas rosental for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous videos game
uh here thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
if you have a suggestion from the EUR
European Team Championship that is being
played currently uh do also suggest in
this video and I will look into your
suggestions uh see you soon